على صعيد العمليات العسكريه قال الجيش
الاوكراني انه خاض 26 اشتباكا قتاليا مع
القوات الروسيه على الجبهات كافه وذلك
خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه وقال الجيش
الاوكراني انه يواصل هجومه نحو مدينه
مولوتو وعلى محور باخم فضلا عن تصديه
لمحاولات هجوميه روسيه على محور افكا و
مارينكا
وفي موسكو نشرت وكاله ريانو فوستي مقطع
فيديو نقلته عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت
فيه انه يوثق لحظه استهداف مستودع ذخيره
تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده كيسيفا في
مقاطعه خيرسون جنوبي البلاد تظهر الصور
الملتقطه عبر طائره استطلاع لحظه تصاعد
الدخان من الموقع المستهدف دون ذكر اي
تفاصيل بشان الخسائر
قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه زبروجيا ان شخصا قتل واصيب اخر
بجروح في قصف روسي على بلدات عده في
الاقليم وذكرت الاداره ان ان القوات
الروسيه نفذت 130 هجوما طال 27 بلده في
المقاطعه خلال اليوم الماضي واوضحت ان 116
قذيفه استهدفت بلدات عده منها يوركي
ويخوف وجيبولي ولي فادني قد الحق القصف
دمارا في 15 مبنى
سكنيا